on Tuesday night I gave the order for  British forces to take part in military  action in Iraq  mr. Blair wrote to President Bush with  an assurance that he would be with him  whatever  he has existing and active military  plans for the use of chemical and  biological weapons which could be  activated within 45 minutes the threat  posed by Iraq's weapons of mass  destruction WMD  were presented with a certainty that was  not justified  mr. Blair overestimated his ability to  influence US decisions  I accept full responsibility without  exception and without excuse I did it  because I thought it was right and  because I thought the human cost of  inaction of leaving Saddam in power  would be greater for us and for the  world in the longer term  you